trying to look for I don't trust this
place I don't trust anyone ever yeah
gifting my fish if I know right done
well John alright buddy I'm just gonna
leave you here and check out this area
how you doing how's everyone doing I
just gave doing I won't be on fire but
it is nice I don't appreciate you know I
got debit alright that's cool
you know what I do kind of travel time
so it's really not that big of a deal
for me I got a guy this is the accident
right yes what's going on here
give me dagger no Oh what this is that I
have to do
it's go ahead yeah I think I missed
something in here shamefully because I
oh there it is
laughter I did that that was the worst
[ __ ] singing ever all right we got
ourselves a rush to key okay now why
don't you go maybe over here but I have
to get Stefano don't die he'll be fine
he doesn't even know where he's up and
down Japan oh he can walk by himself
let's check this place out anyone here
hello anyone in this corridor god damn
it why should you go only do laughing
clown cough cough Lana big balloons all
right it's like all right all right this
way
I got damn order this way I just walk in
a circle thank God oh nice way oh no you
are this way all right this is a maze oh
no I hate mazes I always get lost
look at this [ __ ] I got a lot ah come on
well I'm probably gonna solve this in
two seconds because I have a degree in
maze solving ability got it last year
actually even all right maybe we should
go out there
helau
forced-air walking to the last table
shows the ride doesn't matter anymore I
don't even care my best amazed was like
dirt pity just pity just like it hurts
me just watching you can you please stop
running around for so [ __ ] long
alright thank you game I much appreciate
it
oh no I'm back here are you [ __ ]
kidding me I hate you game why do you do
this [ __ ] to me
why I did nothing nothing to the service
you're just gonna teleport me back when
I'm close to my victory
oh I'm [ __ ] now I am [ __ ] pissed now
follow the [ __ ] light they say well
I'm following up
no I would not I would - laughs you sons
of [ __ ]
turning left real like I just walking
circles dad is freaking cool let go
right this time walking down forward
walking down turning left ye turning
left turning right turning being lost
for our our our [ __ ] dead am even
though I know it I know I turn around to
the left to the left
everything is following in that
[ __ ] boxer laughs walking
straight walking straight [ __ ] this
[ __ ] check I am lost I am lost
[ __ ] this [ __ ] chair classified all
going down the stairs for probably the
fifth time probably should consider a
new solar strategy singing turning left
and mine doesn't seem to be RI ye
walking in and dead end
turning back around them gear I'm not
going straight going left
uh-huh uh-huh walking far away walking
farmer Oh walking right yeah walking
walking straight yeah yeah walking left
walking right thoughts of [ __ ]
walking right I take their [ __ ] sons
of [ __ ] walking there oh you walking
straight this time walking straight this
time [ __ ]
this is that am walking laughing right
this is walking ride this is that you're
gonna like that I walk laughs [ __ ]
ride yes
[ __ ] I'm actually happy holy [ __ ] yes
this sounds of [ __ ] hahaha oh no no
no I'm a lower Saturday tit what is this
no let's not go to religion
oh don't tell about mr. tally [ __ ]
Mayer stupid [ __ ] game oh no oh I'm
just gonna go down yes
[Applause]
ah okay I'm actually really really happy
I'm probably gonna edit that part but I
ran around for good about 20 minutes my
penis what's going on here hey more
water that is lovely
look at me splash hey I hit my head
Jesus Christ she wear a helmet why I
mean it's Carter all right I'll green
water I love you
[Applause]
okay so I got to go away
oh you're a fine steamed thing indeed
I like all right that was a completely
pointless maybe we can stab this Oh
[Applause]
watch it did I come from here no
probably not problem in there no
senorita what's the point of this place
I don't understand
polish okay I don't even I don't like I
don't like you and I don't like I don't
like anyone in Israel aren't you all to
be very [ __ ] better than [ __ ] not
even you might shut up yeah why would I
care tell me all right I did that I did
that you see that [ __ ] where's my
applause nice where are the apron eyes
where are the [ __ ] out dad so ever well
don't mind if I do
I hear that [ __ ] I'm just gonna jerk
that [ __ ] all night long that's what she
said
okay what did we write down absolutely
nothing that's and barrel is just trying
to be hardcore if you're not hardcore
get that the fair
we got here I can use in my head that's
gonna that's alright now alright I will
need mud of these things
maybe there's something modern I do we
get it oh how do you do this exactly
photos oh no what do i do what do i do
what do i do I do a ladle oh yeah it's a
penis ah come on
this go where's my tom says go huh I
don't even know I made it
you mad brah brah they would subside to
senior business six tried to escape but
they were father dealt with in our
prison 120 prisoner to prisoner hey told
us 25,000 I am rich
can you be quiet out there
shut up no one likes you hey Alice
Bailey Jesus Christ how long were you in
there nays be honest I don't know maybe
two minutes don't lie to me I heard that
[ __ ] all right what do we got here a for
pay the machine that keeps the pressure
on this May big metal penis in the
sewers standby to reactivate we need
Institute six red yellow and blue
actually yellow and we fail due to wear
card where's Alice reading but we
already said a lot but I like saying it
don't judge me and I like spinning too
[Music]
what's going on here it's gonna go ooh
neat here all right hi very well it
seems that we have come to a puzzle part
a note today was a beautiful day the
wind was warm and I saw a butterfly
right Nick they come from above and the
great blue sky at the center of was a
red one
he was alone it reminds me of my own
when I was a very young russian boy my
bad
get out of here this is my heart ah you
try to hide [ __ ] from me this is
cogwheel important ha tell me is it
important why you don't answer me your
[ __ ] barrage I know it was important
you always try to hide [ __ ] from me I'm
sure - it just seems that we have to
find barrels please very beautiful poem
I read that before about the butterflies
they're mine stop hiding [ __ ] from me ah
[Music]
don't break it ok I'm gonna end this up
so here sorry there wasn't much action
more like puzzle solving and me running
around in a maze but sometimes you got
to use your brain everyone you know why
that was some inspirational words from
peopie you could write it down in your
general if you want him anyway I like
your favors you enjoyed it subscribe to
come abroad today and I'll see you in
next video
[Music]
sorry Thomas
they get jobs get there any bigger than
that and that that
Oh
ah c'mon dammit ha